USBC was supposed to save us from the
every device uses a different cable
problem what went wrong look I love USBC
connectors I love the Symmetry I love
how they look and yes tons of phones and
laptops have moved to using USBC with
one notable exception this is really
exciting one cable that fits everything
Until you realize that all these cables
look the same but are not the same some
will charge your device but not transfer
any data others will charge your smaller
device but not your larger device some
work as monitor cables others don't some
can transfer up to 40 gigabytes per
second others can only do 5 gigabytes
per second which is a huge difference if
you're actually trying to move large
video files
okay on top of that some companies have
added their own proprietary Tech into
these USBC cables Apple loves that
proprietary Tech even as a Bonafide nerd
Gearhead I still find myself deeply
frustrated by this I mean just look at
this ridiculous chart uh so maybe going
from this to this wasn't all that it was
cracked up to be